[موسيقى]
هل تحولت الحرب في اوكرانيا الى حرب
مسيرات يسقط الاوكرانيون 16 مسيره في هجوم
على مناطق التماس جنوب شرقي البلاد ذلك
بعد ساعات من هجوم روسي بالمسيرات على
العاصمه
لم يقف الاوكرانيون مكتوفي ليدي اطلقوا
مسيراتهم كذلك في العمق الروسي يعلن حاكم
فرنج الروسيه اسقاط ثلاث مسيرات اوكرانيه
المسيره الاكثر خطوره كانت تلك التي اسقطت
على بعد كيلومترات قليله من محطه الطاقه
النوويه في مقاطعه كورسك الروسيه الحدوديه
الهجمات الاوكرانيه دفعت الكرمليل للتعليق
بالتاكيد ان الدفاعات الروسيه تعمل
بفعاليه ليست المسيرات وحدها التي تحلق في
سماء المعركه تصل قنابل عنقوديه الى
القوات الاوكرانيه تلك قنابل يقول
الاوكرانيون انها ستغير مجرى المعارك وان
الروس قلقون منها لانهم يعلمون مدى
فعاليتها في المقابل تحذر موسكو من ان
القوات الاوكرانيه لن تلتزم بالقيود عند
استخدام هذه القنابل او اختيار الاهداف
بهذا تكون هذه الادوات العسكريه صغيره في
حجمها كبيره في تاثيرها لكن الامر يتوقف
على من سيحسم الامر على الارض